how do you plead guilty
of this
[Music]
what's going on he's trying to use his
powers ma'am
[Music]
are you guilty or not guilty sir
[Music]
oh really and who should we have
[Music]
that's quite an accusation
[Music]
i sent it to you to be reset next case
please
[Music]
okay fine willing to accept that
i am loki of asgard
and i am burdened with glorious purpose
[Music]
appears to be a standard sequence
violation
hands up you're coming with us
what we actually got a lot of those
yeah some of the guys use them as paper
weights
whoa this is worthless
[Music]
what are you doing your salad is asgard
no
in this city it's not as gorgeous just
hang in there i want that salad
certa will destroy asgard no matter what
i do
no don't do this that's the apocalypse
obliterates
the salt
don't they know i'm busy spoiling myself
i'd never stab anyone in the back that's
such a boring form of betrayal
okay i've studied almost every moment of
your entire life
you've literally stabbed people in the
back like 50 times
i'd never do it again because it got old
wow must have been
would-be princesses or perhaps another
prince
a bit of both i suspect the same as you
i think that uh you know what's more or
less because what did he just say wow
can we said he was gay and i'm just
curious
what you meant by that exactly i mean
i'm gay
holy holy [ __ ] eminem's gay on our show
i understood that reference another
[Music]
you you conniving craving pathetic worm
oh [ __ ] here we go again please please
no more please i beg you
i'm a horrible person i get it oh [ __ ]
are we the baddies
what big three the big three white big
three androids aliens and wizards
that's not a thing that's definitely no
it's not you're telling me that things
are loki too
oh yes
okay fine willing to accept that
you are my best friend dude
he's so ugly i love him
can i go show my friends yeah of course
sweetheart go ahead
so you're all after the giant cloud
monster too then well we um
we haven't decided how we're gonna kill
it sorry come again kill it
yes we're gonna kill goliath oh my god
that was your plan
not a great plan
[Applause]
thank you my friend
you're my favorite
[Applause]
hello
hi heroes this is stan lee coming at you
we're all part of one big family
the human family and we all come
together
in the body of marvel
this is
what i i see this is an
absolute win you're fighting so you can
watch everyone around you
die think sylvie thinks you'll outlast
every fragile insignificant being on
this planet
you live to see this world crumble to
dust and
blow away
[Music]
i'm so confused these are confusing
times
and today i'm the age you were when you
left
we were on the verge of greatness we
were this close
to providing peace security for the
galaxy